ce conte êtes vous déjà on tient une
brève sur les cales et cercle
psychopathe qui faisait du recouvrement
sur paris à 10 ans du livre le pognon
vie quand tu reviens on remet les
compteurs à zéro au tapis chez nous on
est des vendeurs de sodas ne connaît
rien au trafic de came
plus géré mais j'attends les soins
étaient des faux
quels sont les documents envoyés à 6 ans
c'est pas si grand paris on va les
retrouver n'étaient pas censés plus
jeune espoir et sert qu'ils n'étaient
pas censés rester un taux de seuil
j'ai besoin que tu me fasses confiance
une dernière fois tu crois qu'il serait
malheureux c'est arrivé quelque chose
et qu'est ce que tu veux faire lui tirer
dessus il faut jamais nous lâcher même
les prisons mexicaines n'ont pas réussi
à tuer j'aurais eu 20 t pas l'assassin
millan
demain le jour se lèvera et tous ratés
lisent
partir pour qu'on voit partout
c'est mon ami merde
eto'o
le monde vers le bas